Hello Internet, welcome to… my couch. Where,
I gotta be honest, I did not want to do this
episode. No joke, I was actively looking
for excuses not to do this episode and yet,
each time I shelved it, ever since
the Try Guys drama first started,
my feed has just been full of entertainment news
media making like the worst takes possible about
this situation. Saying stuff that wasn't
just cringe, wasn't just facepalm worthy,
but was just actively making me and everyone
else on the team mad because of how ignorant
and irresponsible it was. So as a YouTuber and
as a business owner, it felt like I had to sit
down on the couch and set the record straight
to call out a lot of the problems that they're
having as it relates to this wider issue. So
consider this my open letter to mainstream media
friends. Strap in because Film Theory is getting
its own first ever serious couch time episode.
Oh, I was supposed to stay over on Game Theory,
so if you've ever existed on the internet
or you're even not on the internet,
you're probably familiar with the Try Guys
at this point. Keith, Zach, Eugene and Ned.
The four of them got their start
on BuzzFeed during its heyday,
becoming one of, if not the first format on
the site with a recurring cast of popular,
relatable characters. And their show was
simple but effective. The guys try things.
No clickbait there, it is all there in the name.
They put themselves out of their comfort zones to
wear women's high heels or wear women's Halloween
costumes or wear women's underwear. You know what?
Come to think of it, there was a lot of wearing
women's sexy things in the early days, but there
was also plenty of other videos out there, like
watching them learn to dance, ballet or race dune
buggies or play Rocket League. Admittedly,
not all of them were bangers, but still,
it was fun to watch these guys these fish out of
water experiences as these complete newbies were
learning all about the weird, wacky, interesting,
dangerous things in the world around them.
Eventually they decided to break off
from BuzzFeed. Because, let's be honest,
everyone made that decision and they decided to
create their own production company. Second Try.
Without a corporate overlord. Suddenly they were
free to make and do whatever
they wanted with their brand.
And you know what? That's exactly what
happened. They took their brand and they
made it into everything that they wanted
it to be. Live shows, merch, podcasts,
spinoff shows, books, documentaries, interviews
with important people like Dr. Fauci. They even
got themselves a show on Food Network, which
then brings us to recent times and the drama.
About a month ago, the try guys had to
fire one of their founding members, Ned,
the one with the house from those clips earlier.
The reason for this? Well, it came out that he had
been having a long term workplace affair with
a Try Guys producer and production manager for
productions like their documentary and their
spin off show Food Babies. Put a pin in that,
we're going to come back to it. After the
firing the remaining tri guys, with an
I…get it because there were three
of them left? It's a lame joke,
other people have made it, but they made
it to me first, so I get to claim it.
Anyway they made a video about the
situation to their 8 million subscribers.
So now that you're caught up with all of that and
we've spent the last page of the script talking
about the history of the Try Guys. Throw it all
away, because I am here to tell you that at the
end of the day, this video is not about them.
It's not about their drama. This couch time talk
is all about the mainstream media and how they
covered this entire situation. You see, in the
aftermath of the team ousting Ned the Internet
just blew up with coverage about this situation.
Wall Street Journal, CNN, Vanity Fair, Cosmo,
The Sun and the coverage was fine for the most
part. I mean, there was a surprisingly large
amount of it, but it was you know, it was okay.
It was neutral. It stuck to the facts, the
publicly made statements, things like that.
But then, in a desperate bid for relevance,
Saturday Night Live decided to enter the chat
with a sketch that is so off the mark that it
single handedly wanted me to make this video.
In a fit of rage I drafted the script up, but
ultimately I calmed down and let it pass. I mean,
I was worried about SNL here. If I were
to make a video about every single,
unfunny, out of touch sketch that the air.
Well…
I’d have infinite content. What
a brilliant channel idea. Anyway, I let it go and
about a week passed and everything was fine until
yet another article was published about this whole
situation, this time from the New York Times.
And again, it missed the entire point
of the situation using lines like this,
quote, right here. The whole thing felt
a bit like a hostage video. This is in
reference to the three guys sitting on the
couch informing their audience about the
steps that they took in removing Ned from
the channel, as if there were people just
off screen with rifles and high
expectations. There sort of were.
They were on the other side of the camera
and miles of fiber optic cable. And the Try
Guys found themselves in a position where,
however shocked and betrayed their audience,
felt their own livelihoods depended on
appearing, equally distressed, appearing.
It made this whole thing out to be just a
glorified performance actions done only for show
in order to appease an audience that somehow had
them imprisoned. Heck, the whole thing ends with
this incredible line. You can imagine Ned Fulmer
watching the video, seeing his former friends
solemnly tamping down the freshly laid dirt, all
in an effort to mollify an audience of strangers
and realizing that however badly he may have
messed up, he was finally free. Oh, boy. Okay,
so there is a lot to break down there. And all of
it highlights mainstream media's mishandling of
both online creators and, more importantly,
workplace issues like the MeToo movement.
So let's just start with the YouTube stuff,
because that one is far less important. Now,
I think it's no secret here on the
Channel that I'm not the biggest
fan of traditional media coverage of
our industry. I've talked about it
on this channel and this channel and
that channel and this channel again.
Is this probably why they don't write
articles about us anymore? It's probably
why they don't write articles about us anymore.
Anyway, just take a look at exactly how SNL
decides to introduce what it is exactly
that the Try Guys do to their audience.
If you look across the wide array of YouTuber
coverage, this one is always the favorite. Call
any type of YouTuber prankster. Jake Paul.
Well, he's a prankster. PewDiePie prankster.
Former NASA engineer, Mark Rober. Well, yeah,
he's the glitter bomb prankster.Mr. Beast.
Obviously, he's a prankster, too. There is
no world where what the Try Guys do would be
described as a prank channel. But yet that
word is a favorite of newspaper coverage
because it evokes such a strong emotional
response when you read about pranksters.
Pranksters aren't people that you're meant to
like. They're not someone that you root for.
The whole “It's just a prank. Bro” crowd
is associated with low effort content that
monetizes people's suffering. Call someone a
prankster and immediately you're sidelining
them in people's minds as someone who is mean
spirited and you probably don't want to succeed.
And of course, it's not just enough to just
write them off as pranksters. You then have
to highlight how much money they're making
off of those pranks that make people mad.
Oh, well, you readers and viewers at home, you
work so hard at your job every day making pennies.
But here are these pranksters on the
Internet making garbage content and
getting rich off of it. Isn't that unfair?
Doesn't that make you mad? The New York
Times article actually takes a different
approach that's even worse than this.
Instead of calling them just mindless
pranksters, the NYT describes the Try
Guys backgrounds like this. A group of friends
becomes a cast of characters and strip mined
lives and relationships for content. If that
doesn't sound flattering? Well, it isn't.
The crux of the entire article is that yeah,
the Try Guys have people who watch them,
but only because they basically
sold their soul to the internet in
exchange for their fame. Except that
couldn't be further from the truth.
The content that's made them so popular is
just classic fish-out-of-water Reality TV.
It's basically the online equivalent of Dirty
Jobs or Wife Swap, where people are put into new,
uncomfortable situations and then they have to
learn to adapt, you know? And no, the irony that
I just used Wife Swap here as an example in this
situation doesn't escape me. But it's entirely
true. Their formats like Cooking Without A
Recipe? I mean, it looks a whole lot like Chopped.
Keith Eats Everything At A Restaurant. Well,
that's just the modern day equivalent of the
eating show Man v Food. And yeah, that one
video that everyone keeps bringing up is an
attempt to embarrass them and tear them down,
the one where they do the unthinkable and try
on women's underwear. Well, that's been a trope
of comedy in media forever. I mean, there an
entire episode of the sitcom F.R.I.E.N.D.S.
that is named after that exact plotline.
You want to go?
Yeah, that’d be great!
Let me make sure I’m not doing anything Tuesday.
They are a media
company with something like 20 employees
and they're producing reality TV content,
something that both of these news outlets
should be familiar with but either aren't
or are disingenuously refusing to acknowledge in
order to prop up a false narrative of “digital
creator bad”. The article then implies that not
only are they milking their lives for content,
but they're actively manipulating their young,
impressionable and emotionally needy audience.
The Try Guys were always bad people.
Ned was just the first one to let the
mask slip. They conjured a nontoxic brand of
masculinity until Fulmer flicked the lights on,
exposing the fantasy. Its severe mood was, in
part, a performance meant to reassure a world
historically anxious and distrustful audience
that they had not been led astray for the
last eight years. Obviously, these
are both really bad looks and pretty
intentionally meant to discredit
not just the current situation,
but the whole system that holds it up. YouTubers
function by fundamentally lying to their audience.
Maybe because they're lowlife pranksters or
because they're just manipulative of kids.
And remember, this is talking about the Try Guys.
The Try Guys are like the Melba Toast of online
content. And that is not meant to be offensive to
the Try Guys or anything they produce. I love the
stuff they produce, but if there is one thing that
Melba Toast is known for, it is being not spicy.
So what could the New York Times or
Saturday Night Live have done? Well,
outside of some very basic research and being
open and honest with their audiences. For one,
they could have connected with the fact
that both of them are located in New York.
And guess what? The Try Guys recently performed
in New York, right down the street at the Great
White Way, Broadway. Or, they’re New York
Times best selling authors. Who also is The
New York Times? Oh wait, the paper that's
publishing this article in the first place.
Synergy. Programmatic synergy friendos. Or if
none of that makes sense, just say that they
got a Food Network show. Hey, you people,
you don't watch the Internet, but you do
watch Food Network because everyone watches Food
Network. These are guys on the Food Network. Done
You understand who they are. I'm just
saying, if the goal was to bridge the
gap in understanding between YouTube and the
readership of a 170 year old publication or a
40 plus year old comedy sketch show,
they could have done it very easily.
They just didn't because that was never
the goal in the first place. So listen up,
mainstream media. Come here, get
up right in my face right here,
because I'm going to get real
with you guys for a second.
This is the hard truth. Playing ignorant
with the stuff that's going on online is
not the flex that you think it
is. “Whoa. Isn't it funny that
people care about these random dudes
called the Try Guys who try things?”
No, no, it isn't funny. You guys get what,
on Saturday Night Live these days? What,
like 3.5 million views an episode.
And that’s talking about TV numbers,
which we all know is kind of like…
they're not really that believable.
Regardless. Guess what? That random online Keith
guy? He got just as many views from eating Panera.
You are currently trading short term jabs at
the “wackos on the Internet” for your long term
relevance. Or maybe you're only aware of online
content to the extent that you can steal it.
That right there? That is Joel
Haver. Amazing online channel,
by the way. You know what, Joel? I
have to disagree with you, though,
because I watched the two videos side by side
and I don't think they're similar at all.
For one thing, your video is actually funny.
Oh, I'm going to get raked over the coals for
this one, I am making no friends. Because
here's the thing. I'm not even all that
concerned about this one. Yeah, sure. I
get really mad about how they reported
and mishandled this entire situation around
online creators, but also at this point,
I've come to expect it. That is just par for the
course. We get no respect over here. The real much
bigger issue with all of this and the true reason
I had to sit down on this couch was because both
outlets horrendously mishandled the core issue
that prompted Ned's removal in the first place.
The entire controversy that led up to this
is framed simply as “Ned Fulmer sharing a
consensual kiss and not telling his
BFFs about it.” And let me be real
clear about this, because no media
outlet seems to grasp this concept.
The Try Guys are not some group of
buddies. They are not just hanging out,
making some videos for the lols on the
weekend. They are a legal and financial
set of business partners who own and operate
a very successful, very popular media company.
They have legal and fiduciary responsibilities
to each other and more importantly, to their
employees, which, in plain English, for all
of you mainstream media writers who this is
just going over the heads of means that they
are obligated to put the good of the group
and the company ahead of individuals,
not just because of morals, but because
in a business with multiple owners,
you have a legal requirement. Plenty
of people have affairs. Plenty of
people have open marriages. Frankly,
we don't know the details of that relationship.
And guess what? Who cares? We don't need to know.
Saturday Night Live, though, makes
it sound like severing ties with
Ned was this act of vengeance from jilted friends.
But the truth is that workplace
romances aren't the meet-cute
of the office circa 2004. As a business owner,
a secret boss-dates-employee relationship
is inappropriate in its power dynamics.
But beyond that, if you don't even want
to get that far, it presents massive legal
liability to everyone working inside that
building. And if you're an owner who knows
about it and chooses not to do anything
about it, guess what you're liable too.
If that relationship ends badly, It is
a wrongful termination lawsuit at best
and a sexual misconduct lawsuit at worst. Now,
you don't need to know the details of
those two things, but the point is either
one can easily bankrupt the company and put
dozens of innocent employees out of a job.
So instead, as a responsible business owner,
you just cut your losses and you put that one
employee, that one offending employee, Ned, out
of a job. It's math, not intrigue. It's ethical,
and it's good business. The Saturday Night
Live skit, though, not only tries to awkwardly
diminish this relationship as a kiss between
coworkers as opposed to what it really was; a
long term relationship between boss and employee.
It then goes on to do what I am most offended by,
to frame Eugene, Zach and Keith as angry, betrayed
friends. As opposed to what they really were.
Angry, betrayed business owners trying to do
the right thing. The New York Times article
actually takes it further than that, saying
that the Try Guys have to be so miserable,
they have to continue lying to their
fans and maintaining this facade.
But Ned, he must be happy that
he escaped. He got to drop the
mask and he survives to live
on another day. And you see,
that is the wild thing that I just can't wrap
my head around with all of this coverage.
You know who received no blame in either of these
examples? Ned Fulmer In both of these pieces,
it's the remaining three guys that are left on
the couch that look like they're in the wrong.
They're the overdramatic divas, mad, and
ousting their friend out of pettiness. No,
no mention of legally endangering the
company. No references to making your
co-founders implicit accomplices, no talk
about predatory behavior in the workplace,
or how the entertainment industry has this
massive problem with sexual misconduct.
No mention about how Ned built his professional
brand, all about being a loyal family man and
undercut that brand in a way that jeopardized the
livelihood of literally everyone in the business
around him. I mean, all of those would be very
valid and important takeaways from the situation.
Why not mention any of that? Why would
you try to vilify the people sitting on
the couch trying to do the right thing?
Well, it's because if outlets like SNL
decided to talk about that, it might draw
attention to the fact that Saturday Night
Live's been accused of having a bit of a
sexist culture against women throughout
the nineties and 2000s. Not much of a joke
when it's about you, hmmm SNL? For instance,
one woman allegedly was summoned to a
producer's office and shown inappropriate
pictures of him. Other interns have allegedly
been brought to after after parties where,
you know, you could just use your
imagination what's going on over there.
These are serious accusations. And this
is literally just the tip of the iceberg
in some cases. Lawsuits have also added in
SNL creator Lorne Michaels and former cast
members like Tracy Jordan and Jimmy
Fallon to the mix, alleging that they
were aware of this misconduct and
enabled it in one way or another.
Saturday Night Live has had these
issues for decades and has never
once had its owners or creators made
public addresses to the audience to
take some sort of accountability.
Instead, you get sketches like this.
Talk about things that haven’t aged too well.
it's no wonder they're making fun of the guys
on the couch here, because if they didn't,
they'd have to acknowledge that their own
history has a lot more scandal and a lot less
integrity than a bunch of “YouTube pranksters.”
And you see, that is the thing that has
gotten me so frustrated about all this.
That is the thing that's gotten me to
sit on the couch to make this episode.
Everyone keeps pointing to the video that
the Try Guys made on the couch as if it
was some sort of an overreaction,
some sort of over-dramatization.
It wasn't. If anything, that sort of thing should
be the new norm. It represents a generation of
media companies who are trying to do better, to be
better, who aren't willing to sweep scandals under
the rug. Business owners who stay transparent
and take real, meaningful actions when someone
steps out of line, no matter how high in the
company they might be. You shouldn't be making
fun of Keith, Zach and Eugene. You should be
following their example. At the end of the day,
this isn't some weird fluke of the news
cycle or some weird children's obsession.
This is the new generation of entertainment media
companies putting their money where their mouth
is. Who are able to swallow their pride, own up
to their mistakes or their employees' mistakes,
and then sit on the couch for some
serious conversations when they have to.
And from this couch, I got to say, it seems
like we're moving in the right direction. But,
hey, that's just the theory!
A FILM THEORY! aaaaaand cut.